grazie dell'invito grazie all'invito le
mie storie con l'informatica risalgono a
quando ero veramente piccolo perché mio
papà ingegnere laureato al qui al
politecnico di torino e ha sempre spinto
perché io provassi interesse nei
confronti di questo mondo quello dei dei
dei computer
mi ricordo quando veramente da bambino
sono stato accompagnato da lui a
visitare il centro meccanografico si
chiamava dell'università di palermo dove
lavorava mio zio vito di gesù che era un
astrofisico e sono entrato in questo
posto dove c'erano questi armadi con
questi nastri che giravano intervalli
regolari con dei personaggi con il
camice bianco lì davanti delle specie di
lavatrici giganteschi alte così con
delle cupole trasparenti e quelli erano
degli hard disk alcuni di questi hard
disk avevano addirittura la capacità di
20 megabyte
sembra assurdo avevano delle capsule che
si infilavano a pressione e 20 megabyte
e ho un ricordo che sono alcune schede
perforate che ho utilizzato come così
come segnalibro stacco arriviamo nell 82
quando
quella dimensione dell'informatica
improvvisamente entra nella
disponibilità di tutti noi e mio padre
mi regala un commodore vic 20 non il 64
il riff 20 aveva una memoria di 3,5 kg
byte
che significa più o meno quattro pagine
della vostra rubrica di carta a casa ma
neanche una voce della vostra rubrica
telefonica nel telefono che sta tenendo
in tasca in questo momento però quella
quella cosa ha catalizzato oltre che la
mia attenzione l'attenzione di un gruppo
di miei amici di un paio di miei amici
uno dei quali andrea rivetti che
purtroppo non è potuto venire qui che
anche lui si è laureato al politecnico
di torino e adesso fa a quello di
mestiere e ci siamo appassionati di
quella cosa il mondo del computer
c'erano i videogiochi che cc
affascinavano io all'epoca la musica la
consideravo veramente poco
nell 82 avevo iniziato a incuriosirmi al
mondo della musica
in questa cosa qui del wrap dell'hip hop
però abitavo a caserta all'epoca non
avevo contatti non saper pensavo di
essere l'unico al mondo quasi a cercare
quel quel genere mi misi alla sera mi
sintonizzava sulla radio della base
militare americana di di napoli e per
che trasmetteva la musica che in quel
momento andava negli stati uniti e
quindi ho iniziato a sentire grand
master flash furious five iniziato a
sentire afrika bambaataa i primi randi
amsi è però non sapevo che facesse parte
di una cultura così ampia così vasta che
coinvolgeva anche la breakdance che
coinvolgeva il writing quella cosa ha
fatto con le bombolette sopra i vagoni
della metropolitana all'epoca hip hop
era un orologio di gomma profumato
quello dei paninari e vai a pensare che
una cosa così [ __ ] si poteva chiamare
come quell'orologio di merda intendo
e strano è strano pensarlo però fatto
sta che è andata così
quell'anno dopo andrea si compra un
commodore 64 64 kilobyte ragazzi oltre
20 volte la capacità del mio piccolo vic
allora mi sono messo a lavorare
quell'estate avevo 13 anni in un negozio
di giocattoli moon giocattoli di caserta
e lavoravo in vetrina e facevo il
dimostratore di video games ci ha
lavorato per un mese e ho guadagnato
qualche soldino
l'ultimo giorno di lavoro è arrivato un
papa che voleva comperare a suo figlio
il collegio vision il colecovision
ragazzi era la console più [ __ ] che ci
fosse aveva una grafica pazzesca non era
molto diffusa tra i giochi secondo me
erano proprio i migliori provate
scaricatevi un emulatore che che può
stare dentro al vostro nokia da quanto e
piccole la dimensione però sono i giochi
straordinari e io lo guardavo detto
aspetta forse forse
e tu hai bisogno di qualcosa di più hai
bisogno di uno scatto tutti i meriti un
home computer
gli ho fatto un pippone incredibile e
l'ho convinto a comperarsi il mio vic20
lo invitati a casa mia mia madre ha
visto entrare un ragazzino di 13 anni
con un signore e con il suo figlio di
otto dentro casa e li ho portati in
studio e gliel'ho fatto vedere ed è
venduto il mio vic 20 e con i soldi che
ho guadagnato dalla vendita di quelli di
cadenti mi sono comprato usato
pochissimo un commodore 64 con il floppy
driver
business ragazzi e con quel comodo 64 il
mio con quello di andrea con quello di
carlo de franciscis insieme abbiamo
abbiamo creato una specie di squadra un
team andrea era sicuramente più versato
di me nel mondo dell'elettronica aveva
costruito autocostruito una penna ottica
la penna ottica di fatto è come una
penna che ha un sensore che si attacca
al computer e che ti permette di
individuare le coordinate sullo schermo
quindi ci puoi disegnare sullo schermo
che è una cosa straordinaria e noi non
l'abbiamo usato per quello noi abbiamo
l'abbiamo usato in abbinamento un
programma di sintesi vocale che si
chiamava sam sembri saiter che io sapevo
usare abbastanza bene e già mi divertivo
a con le parole e praticamente to
scrivevi una frase e lui con una voce
comprensibile assolutamente disumana ma
comprensibile e rispondeva ai top e ne
abbiamo fatto un programma dove la prima
schermata erano c'erano delle frasi di
introduzione la seconda schermata erano
convenevoli la terza e la quarta erano
insulti pesantissimi ci facevamo gli
scherzi telefonici noi telefonavamo a
casa della gente e senza dover digitare
niente con la penna sceglievamo e questo
era l'uso che facevamo dell'informatica
a un certo punto abbiamo iniziato a
utilizzare i disassemblare abbiamo
iniziato a guardare dentro ai programmi
come sono fatti con cos'è il linguaggio
macchina come sono stati programmati
questi giochi e queste capacità come le
abbiamo messe a frutto un amico ci ha
messo in contatto con
un signore di napoli
apro una parentesi i giochi per il
commodore 64 erano diffusi su
audiocassetta su delle cassette normali
quelle che si utilizzano per la musica e
le audiocassette avevano all'interno dei
suoni che sembravano comunque lo stesso
principio del fax no quando ascoltate un
fax e la stessa roba sono dati audio
messi in forma audio quei dati in forma
audio veniva registrati sulle
audiocassette e potevi caricare i
programmi li metteva dentro scrivilo
ripartiva e dopo venti minuti mezz'ora
45 minuti i programmi più complicati
vedo qualcuno che ride perché si ricorda
cosa significa aspettare un'ora e un
quarto e poi scoprire che non aveva
caricato bene e [ __ ] e questa cosa ha
rappresentato un grande impulso per la
diffusione dei programmi del computer e
perché era era facile perché per
duplicare un un programma avevi una
doppia piastra come quelle che
utilizzati per duplicare le
audiocassette e copiate il programma e
lo distribuibile davide i tuoi amici e
avevano iniziato in italia a frugarsi
delle delle riviste su cassetta che si
trovavano in edicola e un andava in
edicola e comperava una cassetta con
sopra quattro o cinque giochi questi 45
giochi e non è che erano stati diciamo
programmati da qualcuno per essere messe
su una cassetta che finiva in edicola
erano dei giochi a cui venivano
modificate le scritte del titolo
all'interno del programma e quindi
quello che era pac man diventava putman
quello che era summer games diventava
olimpiadi e veniva divulgato è un amico
ci ha messo in contatto con questo
signore e di napoli che siamo andati a
trovare
in un posto in cui bisognava scendere
una rampa di scale puoi girare e
scendere un'altra rampa di scale ed era
buio non c'erano finestre ed era un
locale grande tre volte questa stanza
pieno di scaffali e su questi scaffali
c'erano registratori registratori e
registratori solo doppie piastre di
registratori in un posto che ci aveva
camorra scritto enorme su tutte le
pareti e li facevano le cassette pirata
quelle le cassette pirata quella roba lì
la pirateria quella vera quella con con
la benda sull'occhio e e siccome noi
sapevamo come si cambiavano le scritte
dentro dentro i programmi abbiamo fatto
i pirati per davvero senza non chino
senza la gamba di legno con la
tranquillità di essere di risultare
comunque impuniti perché in quel momento
in italia
bisognava prima spiegare alla finanza
quale fosse il problema e poi
eventualmente essere perseguiti perché
non c'era ancora una forte percezione
del concetto di di pirateria stacco nel
tutta questa cosa per me finisce perché
insieme alla mia famiglia ci trasferiamo
da caserta a città di castello in umbria
dove diciamo la penetrazione della
camorra era ancora non così forte e
quindi non non avevo più quella quelli
introito diciamo regolare mensile
mi sono dovuto organizzare soprattutto
non avevo non avevo quegli amici con cui
partecipare attivamente di nuovo non
avevo nessuno mi sono trovato da solo
allora per un periodo ho scritto delle
recensioni
ho scritto
un annuncio sulla rivista il paninaro è
vero
giuro faccio outing e per avere delle
lettere da parte di paninari per capire
questi come se parlassero e avevo avuto
la conferma parlano tutti nella stessa
maniera
iniziavano nella stessa maniera finivano
nella stessa maniera storpia ma le
parole tutto in quel modo
ho imparato la lingua e una volta che mi
sono impossessato della lingua
ho iniziato mi sono proposto come autore
di recensioni di videogiochi per la
rivista wild boys un'altra rivista di
paninari rivale de il paninaro così
facendo o sono entrato in contratto con
la mastertronic che era l'unica ditta
italiana che importava i giochi
originali
io ricevevo a casa mia i giochi
originali li copiano scrivevo una
recensione in un dialetto vergognoso
vendevo la recensione vendevo il gioco
pirata vendevo il gioco originale a un
negozio di città di castello
business fucking business ragazzi ma non
mi bastava non mi bastava mi sentivo
solo e quando uno si sente solo e se un
appassionato di computer ti fai l'amica
un'amica 2000 bellissimo bellissimo
questo questa città dove non avevo molti
contatti grazie all'amica ho iniziato ad
averne iniziato da verne è arrivato lì
io non avevo nulla se non dentro al
cuore la voglia di conoscere persone con
le quali poter instaurare delle
relazioni come avevo a caserta
avevo la passione per i giochi computer
la pirateria e il business per l'appunto
è che il business illegale possibilmente
e questa nuova cosa che coglievo
raccoglievo questa cosa qui dell'hip hop
questa cosa qui dell'hip hop con un
amico che ho conosciuto lì a città di
castello lorenzo mercati abbiamo
iniziato a fare delle cassette ma non
cassette pirata cassette audio
avevamo un giradischi e una cassetta e
un mangiacassette praticamente per poter
fare quello che facevano i dj
utilizzando due copie dello stesso disco
usando due giradischi noi registravamo
un pezzettino fermavamo che eravamo
fuori con la matita si tornava indietro
di un quarto di giro si rimetteva dentro
in pausa si ritornava indietro con il
disco e si ripartiva e si registrava una
sequenza di pezzettini di batteria uno
dietro l'altro in maniera ad avere una
cosa che fosse in qualche maniera fluida
che fosse bella piacevole però ragazzi
che porcate che uscivano erano
imbarazzanti
tra le persone che ho conosciuto l'ho
conosciuto una meravigliosa che
purtroppo non c'è più e sono me pietro
bini era il farmacista di città di
castello una persona di una generosità
meravigliosa uno che era capace di
appassionarsi alle cose e diventare il
master di quella cosa nel giro di manca
una settimana e lui aveva un'amica che
culo che culo essere amici di pietro
bini una cosa che ovvero augura i
migliori e una volta mentre ero a casa
sua gli spiegavo quello che facevo con
lorenzo e dicevo ehi ma sai che faccio
questa cosa con un mio amico
certo che se avessimo un campionatore e
perché con il campionatore è facile con
il campionatore tu fai una specie di
fotografia di un pezzettino di audio di
un giro di tum tum ciacci che tu cic e
poi lo riprova lo ripropone lo riproduce
in avanti avanti avanti ma i
campionatori costavano prima guardato ho
detto aspetta un attimo e andato di là è
tornato è arrivato con una scatoletta
nera con un no di volume sopra un
ingresso e una presa perfetta per essere
attaccato dietro una migra dico guarda
questo credo che sia un campionatore
l'ho comprato un ma non me ne faccio
niente non so neanche come si usi
sinceramente magari tu le puoi fare
qualcosa di meglio e meno regalato
quello era un campionatore monofonico 8
bit ovvero la cosa più piccola più
striminzita che si potesse trovare
all'epoca ma era un cazzo di
campionatore il primo campionatore della
mia vita e io usando quel campionatore
sono tornato a casa e ho iniziato a
provare come farlo funzionare
e ho scoperto che era possibile
campionare i singoli colpi della
batteria e utilizzando dei programmi
metterli in sequenza e pian piano
ho realizzato la mia prima base che non
è quella che è stato e sentendo in
questo momento perché questa è la bella
copia per quando nel 1991
ho scoperto di non essere da solo ma
c'era un intero mondo vinto artisti che
qui a torino a milano a roma alla spezia
facevano l'importo lo realizzavano io
sono tornato a casa e nella stessa notte
ho scritto questa canzone padre contro
figlio fratello suo fratello partoriti
navello come carne da macello pulini con
anime sottili come lamine dagli enti
commenti minerario sotto ogni limite
eroi senza una terra che combattono una
guerra tra la mafia e la camorra sodoma
e gomorra napoli e palermo sociali
dell'inferno divorate dall'interno in
eterno da un tessuto tumorale di natura
criminale mentre il mondo sta a guardare
e muto senza intervenire basta alla
guerra tra famiglie e aumentata dalle
voglie di una moglie collettori dietro
cita la vita e figlie domani e la moglie
rami spogli dalle foglie che l'italia
come paglia e nessuno se la piglia e la
vigilia ad una rivoluzione alla voce del
padrino ma don vito corleone occhio
molto più vicine sia seduto in
parlamento e momento di sferrare
un'offensiva terminale e ci silva
radicale vissuti ma oggi viti più di
prima alle cosche boscheri altitudini
nostri e mantenute da le mosse
alimentato dalle barche
basta una busta nella tasca giunse in
questa italia così lei da giocara faida
you can a fight da faida buy da neutral
a buy da neutral a buy da luca wright
faida più dalla faida
sud non tifare castrare dal potere
criminale che ti vuole fermare guastati
la festa abbassargli la cresta guarda la
sua testa a rotolare nella cesta
liberalamente dagli assurdo pregiudizio
è l'inizio della fine del suffisso che
da secoli ci domina cicogna ciri bobby
da potere di quei demoni che noi
chiamiamo uomini che uccidono altri
uomini risultano voi giovani tagliano le
ali agli angeli più deboli potere che
soggioga potere della droga potere uno
stato che di tutto se ne frega strage di
bologna ustica anche la dion comuni di
scheletri abbassati in un armadio olio
di semi e germogli della terra te con
dato dal sangue della guerra e la
camorra indomita ricca e strafottente
continua ad uccidere la gente e donne
che le raffiche di mitra pacilio di
balletto cosenza potenza card è molto
intensa consacrata la violenza senza
opporre resistenza
il salento un solo movimento fumi sul
sistema prevediamo un cambiamento da
cucina terra basta con la guerra tra
strano intifada gioca la parità baida
you can buy da neutral a buy
ccc 7 benvenuta renew tariqa poco poco 7
femmine un pacco l'europa come luci luci
7 milano c erano c'e duratura 7 femmine
la mola e la mura venire dei sette bimbi
non sospetti o un serpente avvelenato 7
mimino granai funzionato a faccia corsa
7 femmine ed appoggia appoggi in tv
sostiene e la busa ma forse fina fina
settemila fan cena mancina e calma senti
femminile la marca avanza quindi poi la
serie b b linea rosa e la roma xi di
scale 7 chi minh ordinale o fai da te
vai dai da lugano spider faida lucano
grazie
[Applauso]